bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café o el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
difusor público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a las dos y cuarto por las redes
sociales en internet y esta emisión
también se encuentra disponible en
nuestro sitio
eres el inet punto o sea este
programación de tics es un espacio
dedicado a compartir sus mensajes
nuestro correo electrónico es am la
arroba eres y net punto sea nuestro
correo regular radio canadá
internacional apartado postal 6000
montreal canadá h 13 3 a 8 y hoy en el
estudio estamos en compañía de paloma
martínez que estás todos
leonardo gimeno legal como ésta sanar
muy bien muy bien bien entonces ya
estamos en pleno mes de mayo se celebró
el primero de mayo con marchas en todas
partes del mundo bastante escándalo en
parís
carmen se combinan con las medidas
económicas que la gente no no no las
acepta
entonces empecemos con las notas lo que
les ha llamado atención a ustedes
a mí personalmente aparte de esta fiesta
del primero de mayo que no me llama la
atención pero porque es una cosa que
siempre se festeja en los que se
recuerda más bien los primeros de mayo
salvo aquí en canadá rufo aunque hubo
algo no en montreal hubo marcha creo que
basta de tensiones manifestaciones en
montreal nada que ver con francia o con
parís porque las las realidades son
diferentes
hubo por ejemplo marchas también en
argentina en brasil fue muy muy grande y
que es una marcha que se convirtió
finalmente en un pedido de liberación a
lula entonces si hubo luz dependiendo
del lugar donde se celebró pues era un
poquito diferente ahora a mí lo que me
llamó la atención
y es una pregunta que me hago y es un
tema bastante ligero si se quiere pero
tiene un impacto es en la ciudad de
vancouver que una pareja decidió poner
un restaurante y le puso de nombre
escobar que uno pensaría que son
colombianos como - pero no es una pareja
de indios o de ahí de irán no estoy
segura el apellido viene de esos lugares
que no tienen nada que ver incluso con
comida colombiana nada y que nos dicen
que le pusieron escobar con un juego de
palabras también por bar porque su
restaurante en bar pero además como está
de moda se puso de moda por netflix la
serie de los narcos pues pesos pensaban
que podía tener un impacto y lo tuvo
favorable a su restaurante y ellos dicen
por ejemplo nosotros no teníamos idea de
que podría causar problemas porque la
comunidad colombiana en vancouver saltó
la razón creo yo porque para por lo que
representa para la comunidad y los
colombianos lo que pasó en colombia y
con escobar no
esta pareja la mujer ac yo creo una
pregunta que tal vez es interesante o no
dependiendo lo que ustedes piensen pero
ella dijo hay restaurantes que se llaman
con el nombre del mafioso este como era
de capones también hay otro que es
godfather pizza y menciones a todos
estos tipos y nadie nadie toma ningún
tiene ninguna reacción saben que son del
mundo del crimen no se aparten digamos
que en este caso está como se hicieron
conocidos tan tanto al capone como
nosotros es una cuestión de publicación
en este caso en netflix con el bolsín yo
tal claro creo que se haga referencia ni
lo hagan puesto para recordar finales
regular ellos no aclaró pero es es que
esta pareja blog tomó muy ligero al tema
estás pero mientras que para los
colombianos que a iquique aquí y además
creo que escobar es un poquito diferente
al capone si se pone a ver el impacto
que tuvo en colombia en la sociedad
civil colombiana
mientras que al capone pues para mí era
un delincuente un mafioso y que bueno
disparaba más bien a la policía oa otros
mafiosos no sé si dicen que los dueños
son indios entonces quizás qué pasaba si
llamaban strand gandhi era vegetariano
lustran iraní que se llama ayatolás
pero el argumento de esta pareja sobre
ellos pareciera que no tendrían ningún
problema no quizás eso se puede ver por
la cultura popular porque me percibe
cuando en los años 40 y 50 cuando ambos
hacía papeles de ensayos y visitaba
ciudades presentando su película lo
teníamos no le mandaban sus mensajes
diciéndome que él a los mafiosos le
presentaban sus respetos profesional a
caramba y muchos mafiosos en los años
ochentas noventas declaraban que ellos
veían las películas del padrino para
saber cómo vestirse
es decir que la magia tal como es toda
esta esta idea de la mafia pues fue
nutrida alimentada creada por la cultura
popular y esto del micro por los medios
claro es que retomaron la cultura
popular se apropia de todo eso y lo
transforma finalmente no no señor quizás
no hay medio medio cínico pero que el
francia-méxico vale pues que no creo que
sí pero me preguntaba solamente si
realmente puede herir tanto la
sensibilidad es bueno mucha gente se
manifestó sin pancho villa' tacos la
taquería de pancho villa
acá alguien pusiera a videla pizza
me molestaría muchísimo
pero no es lo mismo un golpe de estado
en un dictador aquí estamos hablando de
otros niveles de cooperación
pero sí creo que hay mucha gente se
sintió ofendida seguro y hubo yo bien
los medios sociales las comunes la
comunidad un latino a canadiense en todo
canadá no solamente en vancouver se
expresó y yo creo que había bastante
bastante descontento alrededor de esta
idea ahora si me preguntas a mí que me
llamó la atención más allá de esto que
sí lo estuve siguiendo en los medios
sociales y me llamó la atención una
noticia
un centro comercial entro a riviera aquí
en quebec finalmente decidió readmitir
la presencia de adolescentes sin adultos
porque había prohibido la presencia de
adolescentes hasta qué edad hasta los 18
años si no tenían un adulto
acompañándolos no querían que entraran
por gay porque resulta ser que algunos
de estos adolescentes saliendo de la
escuela se iban al centro comercial a
pasar el tiempo con sus amigos mucho
exactamente muchos muchos presión los
kilos fue todo con el frío
porque se puede interpretar
el centro depende depende en qué lugar
de américa latina te encuentras en las
latinas se utilizan distintos
pero mintiéndole a los padres si la
viste si te vas pero no vas a la escuela
yo hice eso una vez y me pillaron
inmediatamente entonces nunca más lo vi
estaba tan mal hecho 19 días
consecutivos
a 19 días consecutivos y nunca
denunciaron a tu casa
entonces estos chicos de un es de dos
escuelas cercanas al centro comercial y
van la mayoría de ellos no hacían nada
malo se divertían jugaban comían un
helado platicaban paso de todos los
pelos en los meses del invierno pero uno
que otro o un algunos grupitos e
hicieron algunas cosas que molestaron a
los comerciantes robaban algunas cositas
no eran grandes rateros pero robabancos
molestas y exactamente entonces decidió
el centro comercial no permitir más
lenta de adolescencia sino para no
dejarlos entrar pusieron policías por
todo cuanto a las entradas le salió caro
el tema prohibido para matar 18 menores
de 18 años y sin mayores no podían
ayudar compacto ridículo duró mucho
tiempo porque claro vieron la el vieron
el impacto que eso tuvo en los medios de
comunicación y tuvieron que mandar su
servicio de relaciones
y finalmente si los vamos a aceptar pero
que se porten bien y la policía lo
gracioso es que la policía dijo si hay
algunos en algunos casos que hemos
tenido pero no sé por qué fue tan
radical gran radical la medida porque en
realidad no llama más la atención que
ningún otro centro comercial o sea no es
más ahí que en otros lo que me
interesaría saber es que está la cocina
americana
ahora esta semana a ok entonces en haber
inaugurado no sé qué tal
finalmente el chapo murió nos murió el
que hacía el papel del que hacía el
papel del rubio del del el cuero como le
dicen en la película está murió hace
poco que no sé de dónde era
[Música]
yo tampoco para los amigos en gelatina
que no están viendo si ustedes tienen en
sus ciudades locales con nombres que hay
list
parezcan complicados pues háganos saber
y estamos siempre atentos a sus mensajes
por facebook y también por youtube así
que éste participó con nosotros que
vamos a leer sus comentarios
no insólito pero en realidad se va
tornando insólito con el tiempo este es
un saludo especial a los fanáticos de
star wars hoy es el día de star wars
y 5 de mayo la fuerza hasta el 5 de mayo
y el 5 de mayo
podríamos hablar del 5 de mayo
en mexico se celebró únicamente la
batalla de puebla que es cuando los
muchos mucha gente del pueblo mexicano
un grupo pero sin armas o sin sin muchas
armas
un peleo contra el ejército francés que
estaba presente en méxico y los chicos
salir de allí 20 años 1860 más o menos
63 les decían gabachos a los franceses
oa los cinemas y a los franceses tenía
alguna póliza
porque no sé si la historia popular
cuenta que fue gracias a los franceses
que se quedó el mariachi güines una
variante es una deformación de la
palabra magia quieren estas bandas que
acompañaban con trompetas ya los qassam
en sus actos ya no toda la cultura
popular en méxico es una mezcla es una
es una cuestión mestiza no solamente
viene de los indígenas sino solamente
viene los europeos como una combinación
de todo y en méxico todo es mestizaje
casi todo y este es el mes entonces de
un casey plato con tres colores una vez
es en septiembre porque en realidad la
fiesta mexicana la de la de la
independencia mexicana es en septiembre
entonces menos en eeuu celebran más del
5 de mayo que en mexico en el fondo rojo
quiere saber que se come mañana
bueno pues dulces porque en la época los
en méxico se acercaba mucho a los
conventos donde las monjas preparaban lo
que américa en américa en méjico
llamamos de una manera podríamos llamar
hasta en argentina porque suena mal es
el dulce de leche a la bajita la cajeta
entonces las monjas hacían cajeta o
dulce de leche mexicano y lo andaban
distribuyendo entonces cualquier cosa
dulce con cajeta es en esta época
en realidad 5 de mayo también se hizo
muy popular porque hay un montón de
películas de dibujitos animados que
hacen referencia a 5 de mayo 55 más
no igual si no a mí me encanta
y lo que sí creo es que hay una parte de
esa de esa historia que me que se me
escapa ahora pero tiene que ver también
con la y con la presencia francesa en
eeuu en la misma época todos parece que
por eso el 5 de mayo y lo que los
mexicanos
dieron de sacar a los franceses de
méxico tuvo repercusiones en la
presencia francesa en eeuu entonces pero
me escapa un poco el pero hay algo o
algo relacionado a y por eso creo que en
eeuu tiene más importancia que en méxico
claro en el 5 de mayo como tal ya
entonces nos investigar bien entonces el
5 de mayo es por lo menos mk de norte
son esos grandes afiches de la cerveza
sol sí y sombreros bigotes ya tec y
guacamole bien que destaca no solamente
eso mandarle un saludo grande a todos
los lados de la guerra de las galas
por él
[Música]
lo que pasa es que normalmente cuando
caen fin de semana hacemos una maratón
de películas ya lo pasa es que ya son
muchas o nueve no sé qué pasa todo el
día mis películas no se puede
entonces tendría que ser de 22 semanas
9 otras películas alternativas que son
entre entre películas en la historia
y otra cosa que me llamó la atención y
realmente me llamó la atención y me
gustó leer eso es un exdiputado de
quebec drew
tiene 84 años y acaba de terminar un
doctorado y me lo leí en un radio canadá
justito estaba leyendo antes de venir
los 84 años y haciendo termino de hizo
la defensa de su tesis en la universidad
de laval creo y por eso me parece tan
interesante el tema de si el cerebro
sigue funcionando es decir se aprende y
se aprende hasta el final de los días en
realidad librario que lo dicen los
expertos de magill que entrevistamos no
hace mucho y otros y cualquier en fin la
gente que estudia el problema de la
demencia o alzheimer y todas esas cosas
dicen entren en su cerebro extienda
hasta que se muera igualmente está
comprobado que el tema de la velocidad
de aprendizaje tiene que ver con la
capacidad de poner tiempo en ese
aprendizaje uno dice cómo aprenden los
niños a hablar en dos años hablan y en
tres años hablan dos lenguas y no hacen
nada más que eso no tienen que ir a
trabajar
tiene que preparar comida limpia nada
más que eso pónganme a mi ambiente
asegurando dos años y aprendo cualquier
idioma
para mí no hay hablar de las de este
informe del médico de frank pero ya esa
casa blanca es un circo quizá me parece
más interesante echar una mirada a
méxico justamente que hablamos del 5 de
mayo porque las últimas los últimos
indicadores muestran que lópez obrador
está realmente avanzando a nadie le
sigue y lo que me llamó la atención fue
la declaración de un candidato bronco sí
que dijo que cortarle la mano a
cualquier persona que robará algo que
una forma de contenerla
lo dijo lo dijo además grandes
migraciones esos exabruptos que tiene
trump él en el primer debate de los
candidatos presidenciales lo dijo y
además la la periodista que está una de
las periodistas moderadoras le pregunto
porque él dijo propongo que para a
contrarrestar la corrupción en méxico
mochar y ahí humanos y entonces claro
podría haber sido un poco más figurado
en el sentido de voy a quitar esta
persona del camino si es corrupta pero
la periodista le preguntó usted dice
literalmente cortar manos y dijo sí
literalmente cortarle manos a la mano
aquel que roba el dinero del pueblo y la
reacción y reacciones bueno muchos
muchos meses muchos muchas cosas
graciosas pero también hubo reacciones
duras y las reacciones que me refieres
que realmente hubo cuerpos hubo gente a
la que si la ama
y pusieron en jan y pusieron junto a los
cadáveres el bronco dijo que había que
hacer esto entonces el entonces si mejor
me que entonces pues esas elecciones en
méxico son muy importantes
regionalmente justamente tomando en
cuenta el viraje que ha ocurrido en los
grandes países de la región como
argentina y brasil y vaya uno a ver pues
lo que vaya a pasar de méxico va a tener
una gran influencia en la región y es
claro que es de que desde aquí vamos a
seguir ese tema y entonces se una
versión un radio de este programa
disponible en nuestro sitio es de 6
puntos
les vamos a presentar la música del
canadiense kari move led con el tema la
la la es un cantante pop canadiense
nacido en dakar senegal fue adoptado por
sus padres que eran diplomáticos
canadienses cuando él tenía un año y
vive en francia
wanda y túnez antes de que su familia
pérez a quebec
vamos a escuchar del mexico lila downs
con la canción la bruja y tenía una
canción que viene de un hijo de
refugiados españoles republicanos en
francia se llama lenny escudero falleció
en 2015 a los 82 años hice una canción
muy romántica que se llama una mujer
está oro por un amorcito entonces y nos
despediremos como siempre con el tema de
dedicado a los espías así que espero que
la pasé mal en realidad ahora quien no
espía claro
es que el otro día bueno a partir de lo
que pasó con facebook
cambridge analítica y todas historias
hay un hay un montón de cosas que uno
tiene que uno acepta condiciones
términos de utilización por ejemplo yo
tengo cuatro o cinco aplicaciones una
con la que gerenció las películas en el
servidor de mi casa para que se puedan
ver en todos los televisores otros bueno
dropbox para poner todos los archivos
hay un montón de aplicaciones que uno
usa que utiliza la nube que está en
contacto con directamente con nuestros
archivos en estas últimas tres semanas
al menos ocho empresas me mandaron un
papel diciendo hemos revisado nuestra
tarea no en nuestros términos y
condiciones necesitamos que acepte
nuevamente porque se están escondiendo o
sea evidentemente todos robaban
información ya sea no hay un caso
específico para decir
dropbox hizo tal cosa o aquella otra
empresa hizo tal otra pero para que el
yo tengo un aparatito se llama chrome
cast que es para pasarte en películas en
la tele
comcast me mandó diciendo hemos
verificado los libros las políticas de
confidencialidad o sea evidentemente
nosotros que creíamos que eran las
grandes grandes google facebook
todos son todos absolutamente todos
tienen nuestra información y yo hice la
semana pasada estábamos charlando con
martín y me mostraste y yo bajé la
información toda la información que yo
tengo en facebook y me hice una copia en
particular tengo un giga casi 2 gigas de
información guardada
efe los 9 el wow cosas que yo no he
compartido como por ejemplo la agenda de
mi teléfono guau dentro o sea que para
aquel que pierda su teléfono podría
recuperar la agenda aparte de la copia
de facebook no es increíble la cantidad
de visión impress canaán que uno no sabe
que había compartir ya porque cuando
bajas la aplicación en tu teléfono le
das el permiso a facebook de acceder a
todos tus a todos tus contactos e
incluso gente y me explica vas tú
también me impresionó
e incluso a gente que no está en
facebook bueno facebook tiene la
información de esa gente del círculo en
mí en mi teléfono por ejemplo lo que lo
que lo que entendí el otro día es yo por
ejemplo tengo un nombre de una persona
que no tiene facebook en mi teléfono él
lo recupera recupera el nombre completo
el número de teléfono tú tienes esa
misma persona en tu teléfono
recupere esa información y vos tenés el
ángel y la relación entonces mismo
nombre mismo del teléfono el mail
coincide y vos te hay otra persona que
tiene la dirección postal misma y que
tienen una base la red de datos es
impresionante ahora no sé cómo lo ves
leonardo vos que está siempre en el tema
no sé si es una casualidad o tal vez
para nada de que de ahora facebook se
lanza en un sitio de encuentros ahora va
a ser un sitio para enamorados eso es
pura búsqueda de dinero y algo más
detrás de eso no para mí es increíble y
ahora me está tratando de recuperar y de
eso es lo que el artículo que yo hice
para esta semana es justamente la que
estamos lo digo es una de las
aplicaciones nuevas que trae facebook lo
está haciendo para recuperar gente
porque perdió mucha gente con esta
historia de cambridge analí pero hay
mucho dinero ahí para tener en este
sitio en los sitios de encuentro acción
hay también mucha gente que se va a
meter en esto y es la vía absolutamente
sí sí y aparte está haciendo cosas que
hacen otras empresas como por ejemplo
está sumando a face
sí
funcionalidades que tiene snap chat que
no las tenía facebook hasta ahora
entonces ahora desde facebook no va a
poder hacer lo que hacía con snap chat
lo que hacía contender para encontrar
pareja lo que hacía con esta como
realidad
es un negocio que para mí está perdiendo
mucho precio lo perdió facebook al
prestigio no le queda algo un aumento de
no sé en tres millones cuatro tonos de
persona en estas últimas a partir del
momento después de después de después de
lo que primero cayó hubo un montón de
gente que se fue y la recuperó en una
semana ya y la firma de camps analítica
quebró pero acaba de declararse en
quiebra porque no puede enfrentar todo
lo que se viene dice sin historia que el
leonardo comenzó dando cuenta de los
temas que vamos a tratar esta semana que
recomendamos esta semana entonces ese
tema lo encontramos en el de seis mil
puntos sea así es y tiene que ver con la
f8 que es la reunión que hace todos los
años facebook con sus desarrolladores y
la gente que trabaja
a mejorar la aplicación y la plataforma
en realidad mejorará también por ejemplo
con estas nuevas funcionalidades o sea
pero aparte es bastante interesante lo
de las funcionalidades ha de buscar
pareja porque no es que yo comparto toda
mi información con la otra persona sino
que yo te suscribes aún no sé a un baile
especial dentro de dos semanas y yo
también digo que yo voy a asistir
entonces me hace un máximo de
coincidencias de mis gustos mis
preferencias y me dice estas cuatro
personas tienen que ver con tu perfil
entonces yo puedo ponerme en contacto
con esa persona pero un alias 'juan'
para empezar a tener alguien que sabes
que anda toma un café
si existe si existe pero está
desapareciendo está desapareciendo vamos
a pasar de la manipulación política de
facebook a la manipulación sentimental
exacto
[Música]
bueno entonces qué pasa qué por qué pasa
con o sea que tú tus códigos afectivos
son educación como educación sean la
educación la educación por lo menos no
te enseñan como como
cuando estás en la persona que lo dicen
todos los robos nos van a enseñar los
robots cómo seducir a la gente entre
seres humanos
cosas que yo conozco gente que se
divorció con después de 15 20 años de
casados y que no está acostumbrada a ir
a un bar y no hay bares para ese tipo de
gente entonces se meten esto es lugar de
cita y conozco pareja bien conformada
por intermedio de aplicaciones nadie se
dijo que hace una pareja que se
consignaba live
yo les podemos nombrar a varios que
ustedes mismos conocen que conocemos
seguros existen y funcionan son para
mencionan porque la gente también está
en en realidad para ese tipo de gente
que la que no está habituada a al
encuentro interpersonal porque hace 20
años que no lo hace que las
oportunidades son cada vez menores
también te hablemos de un bar solito a
ver qué atrapas está como si no y ahora
también en el momento
donde uno mira de costado y me estás
acosando es como más difícil en todo
sentido
mujer mujer hombre hombre hombre mujer
mujer es todo puede llegar a ser acoso
todos los códigos han cambiado exacto y
justamente no sé si vieron esta semana
también que de tres muchachitos yo lo
llamo muchos chicos tienen 13 14 años de
uno de los colegios de un colegio en la
cerca de la ciudad de québec fueron
acusados de difusión de pornografía
juvenil porque se compartieron entre
ellos fotos de amigas suyas de la
escuela igual menores como ellos
adolescentes igual y compartieron esas
fotos entre ellos ahora están acusados
de un crimen que es muy grave por no
haber entendido las consecuencias de una
cosa de esta naturaleza es decir los
medios sociales están modificando
nuestras acciones y con esto tiene que
venir acompañado con estas acciones y
cambios de comportamientos tienen que
venir a acompañar la información estos
chicos
digo hicieron algo que no debe hacerse
lo sabemos eso eso no se hace la ley lo
dice no puedes transmitir compartir
fotos de personas desnudas con alguien
más sin su consentimiento de acuerdo
entonces es solo la ley lo dice pero yo
son menores de edad y el crimen de hacer
esa esa difusión de imágenes
pornográficas es muy grave y si son
acusados como adultos bajo este crimen
las penas serán graves también entonces
creo que y lo que ellos dicen los que
argumentan es que son amigas de la
escuela y un saludo a nuestros amigos y
desamores sepúlveda
si éste anotara un saludo ramón siempre
bienvenido el programa ya mismo también
juan carlos miranda duarte gays y
saludos desde chile ya a mi trabajo
nosotros esther ayala así que pues
gracias por acompañarnos y si tienen
reventós chicos eran de una escuela
privada prestigio exista derivadas
bien entonces tú has estado de origami
el punto es que realmente a veces uno
empieza a hacer una entrevista con una
idea y terminas por otro lado eso es lo
que me pasó
esta es una es una película que acaba de
salir acaba de estrenarse del que pensé
que no me huevo en todo caso me vas a
patrick patrick que bueno ya se me
olvidó el nombre patrick de merz acaba
de sacar esta película que se llama
origami para mí el actor principal es
françois arnaud y todo la gente lo debe
conocer por porque es el actor principal
muy conocido en la serie borghi
dicho sea de paso bueno el tema es que
en esta película
bueno la trama ese pasa con este un
joven que se dedica a obras a vender o
curador de obras de arte asiáticas pero
hay una historia increíble que se va
mezclando entre el pasado el presente y
es como un poco dicen el origami
el origami es este arte japonés del
papel que puedes hacer obras de arte con
un origami sin cortar nunca el papel ni
con la tijera ni utilizando goma nada en
fin entonces entreviste a uno de los
actores principales de esta película que
es en milton cannata que es un brasileño
de origen padre japonés madre japonesa
brasileña que vive ahora aquí en
montreal no habla español muy bien a mí
habla muy bien se desenvuelve muy bien
en español y entonces hablando con él y
sobre el rol que él jugaba en esta que
tenían esta película me dice a mí lo que
me ayudó muchísimo a jugar este papel
fue que yo aprendí la danza butoh y sigo
hablando y sigue hablando de otras cosas
porque la y después volvió y dijo eso me
ayuda muchísimo entonces me puse a
investigar después y esta danza butoh y
además él lo nombra al profesor que le
enseñó que es una eminencia en japon el
que enseña esta danza butoh que es una
es una danza yo vi un poquito en
internet
son movimientos lentísimos y con una
precisión impresionante cada movimiento
y entonces él dice que el haber hecho
eso haber aprendido esa danza le ayudó a
jugar ese rol porque como es una
película de no más de 5 millones de
dólares en quebec dice esto no es
hollywood no tiene es un coaching que te
va diciendo cómo actuar como verte pero
eso el hecho de haber actuado para hacer
su papel de un japonés misterioso que lo
ayuda al personaje principal en este
tema porque en el gp game se hace viajes
psicológicos del pasado y del presente
pues me finalmente le puse de título
encuentro del origami con la danza butoh
país realmente ahí hay como una especie
de síntesis entre lo el actor y lo su
aprendizaje en el pasado de esta danza y
como eso le sirvió en la película
origami y aparte de eso por supuesto
hablamos y él hace referencia a los
estereotipos aquí en quebec sobre los
actores que tienen son negros o
asiáticos como él o latinos y que les
cuesta muchísimo encontrar papeles
que se salgan de esos estereotipos rolex
entonces aunque él dice que en que ve
que está avanzando la cosa está
cambiando todavía falta mucho y bueno y
conversamos de otras cosas más y por
supuesto de la película y del lazo de él
y la relación que estableció con el
director con el que escribió el libro
entonces el que quiera pues interesarse
en el tema ahí está la entrevista muy
bien paloma tú estás pues no has tocado
el tema del talco para para los bebés y
el cáncer aunque no el tabaco no usado
en bebés el talco no usa no usado en
bebés porque quienes presentaron una
demanda en contra de dos compañías que
producen estos tacos para bebés
johnson and johnson y valiant fueron
demandadas legalmente por una por un
grupo es una demanda colectiva en que
aquí en canadá podría crear precedentes
porque según el fallo del tribunal
superior de quebec que fue dado este
miércoles se autorizaron ésta autorizó
la demanda entonces no se sabe los
resultados aún por supuesto pero si
ganan su demanda
las mujeres que presentaron esta demanda
pues sería sería un caso impresionante
porque se demostraría que este tipo de
polvo de polvos de sustancias podrían
provocar provocan el cáncer y que las
compañías lo sabían y que los seguían
vendiendo sabiéndolo porque hay pruebas
científicas que aún están siendo
preparadas para presentarlas ante el
tribunal que están que son tal parece
que no tienen no tienen no se pueden
refutar irrefutables entonces en eso ya
hubo casos y una máquina inflama horning
aquí y además que condenaron a la
empresa exactamente entonces si la
empresa pagar muchos millones de dólares
entonces esto sería un caso si en caso
sin presentes en canadá y parece que
aquí en canadá habría alrededor de 470
mujeres canadienses que utilizaron este
talco y que tuvieron como consejo
durante varios años no un día
sin haberlo utilizado durante un cierto
periodo de tiempo y que había provocado
el cáncer en los ovarios de estas
mujeres 470 alrededor en canadá se hace
pensar también es este otro caso del uso
de dos tampones y la reacción química de
la dioxina que hay y causaron
fallecimientos sí porque con lo que con
lo que hacen con lo que fabrican estos
estos instrumentos o éstas es
cancerígeno bien lo que destacó esta
semana lo que les invito a que ustedes
puedan escuchar es una entrevista con
una indígena guatemalteca a lorena
cabnal que ella plantea que la lógica
del pensamiento occidental no es
suficiente como para dar respuesta a los
problemas que enfrentan a todos los
indígenas y replantea algo muy
interesante y ella habla de la necesidad
de una ecología política crítica e
interesante porque estaba en el marco de
universidades y ahí este duelo entre
nuestro éxito eso es son distintas
versiones entre la razón y la y la y la
metodología de ordenar pensamientos e
ideas dentro del campo universitario y
ella que viene a universidad para
explicar otras formas de orden
organizar y el conocimiento
pasa al conocimiento sin embargo ella se
apropia del lenguaje académico de toda
la tecnología destaca que este tipo de
trabajos pero lo que ya plantea es que
hay que dejar de ver a los saberes
indígenas como como mitos o como
costumbres rituales nivel a tsunami como
forma de conocimiento y esto se dio en
el marco de un simposio titulado
perspectivas sociales y teóricas sobre
la verdad la justicia y la
reconciliación las américas y el ángulo
era justamente la memoria la memoria
había una frase que dijeron que le
explicó y decía que justamente sin
memoria no hay justicia
y bueno algunas ideas muy interesantes
adelante porque vivimos siempre con una
noción del conocimiento una noción de la
información una manera de pensar y no
nos abrimos a otras cosmologías otras
maneras cosmogonías claro porque ser
vista como un gato encerrado en la caja
de la racionalidad yo me acuerdo en la
universidad de que ve que aquí de
montreal era una de las grandes
discusiones en un momento dado había
tanta inmigración que si es que llegaba
a la universidad y lo sé por ejemplo en
la facultad de comunicación es uno de
los planteos que hacíamos era porque no
hay autores latinoamericanos que son tan
conocidos que tienen ideas nuevas y que
son conocidos en europa pero no llegan
aquí porque hay un monopolio también
aquí del conocimiento no que proviene
sobre todo de estados unidos y de
francia también dependiendo de donde
finalmente empezaron a llegar de a
poquito no autores como greening jesús
martín barbero que fue traducido al
francés o canclini grandes y que son
tienen un pensamiento original y que
tienen nuevas teorías de las
comunicaciones
también que si también hay una teoría
desarrolló una teoría de la comunicación
que se ve ahora se llama tela y su
colega si no me había concretado tratar
de hizo este librito célebre cómo está
esta mujer explicaba que sin la memoria
la verdad es mentira la justicia ventaja
impune y la reparación son sólo migajas
de una mirada a la historia guatemala no
que es unos países con unos niveles de
violencia increíbles y ella decía que
desde el punto de vista las mujeres las
condiciones de la guerra no han cambiado
porque las mujeres siguen muriendo
entonces es interesante la cooperación
con esta indígena guatemalteca lorena
cabnal son los temas que le recomendamos
esta semana en nuestra nuestra misión y
no podemos acabar el programa sin por lo
menos la lectura algunos mensajes de
nuestros amigos oyentes que se han
tomado el tiempo de poder es
describirnos el cierre de dallas nos
hace
este es un mensaje sobre el tema este de
que un canadiense linchado en perú
estaría vinculado al asesinato de una
sanadora aborigen y hay un comentario
acá que dice al leer este artículo hay
como una aparente contradicción en el
artículo escrito en español y en francés
en canadá internacional
entonces dice la versión francesa dice
que canarias que fue ahorcado o linchado
por una fue por un grupo de personas en
perú era tal vez inocente mientras que
en la versión en español decía un
canadiense linchado en perú estaría
vinculado al asesinato de una sanadora
indígena y creo que hicieron un hicieron
otro artículo en francés
rectificando el tiro en realidad lo que
sucedió es que la información que estaba
saliendo cuando hicieron la primera
noticia en francés no fui yo era a
cuentagotas y después lo rectificaron me
parece bueno hoy dicen que toda la
evidencia apunta al canadiense todo
porque se han encontrado las balas se
corresponden a las balas que él compró
eran de él antes de haber cometido su
habría cometido el asesinato y entonces
se presentó ahora apunta a que fue el
canadiense el que la mató y el que nos
dice esto aprovecho para decirles que me
gustan mucho sus artículos sus
publicaciones y que les decía un gran
éxito en todas las actividades iniciadas
escribe luís eduardo cortés
luís eduardo cortés
a veces a veces a américa latina no sé
por qué escribe en francés agua o
migrante canadiense de américa latina'
dijo
con un mensajito por acá tengo para el
tema en los empleos más buscados por las
empresas canadienses no es matadamas
dice un reconocimiento y gracias a ana
luisa iturriaga por su movilidad y toda
la ayuda para los migrantes pues es
determinante la coordinación para
concretar la ayuda gracias a noé por
este mensaje otro mensaje en este caso
de javier de conocer en un garaje que
comenta sobre la información
aplazan hasta junio el juicio contra
husky por derrame de petróleo no sé por
qué esta empresa postergar la sesión del
juicio si está aceptando su culpa
incluso hasta pide disculpas amigos el
periodismo que ustedes se aplican el
sistema de segi es muy profesional lo
felicito entonces este mensaje de javier
gonzález nungaray aquí tengo mensajes
sobre el tema la expansión del universo
finalmente explicada y lo mandas on jan
y dice buenas tardes quisiera que me
ayudaran con esta pregunta es del
colegio para mi hijo la pregunta es la
expansión del universo son como
proyectiles moviéndose en el espacio
desde un centro común si es como
proyectiles no sé no sé si como
proyectiles pero sí creo que a partir de
un centro común ahora lo que pensando en
él o en el espacio en el universo me
quedé asombrada de verla el último
trabajo que hizo hopkins sin que lo
publicaron ahora y que dice que el
universo es finito infinito
eso es me impresionó este artículo en
forma de tortuga
pero me lo dice porque y esa es una es
una en trabajo que él hizo y que luego
iban a poco que había sido ya aceptado
para ser publicado antes de su muerte y
que lo acaban de publicar entonces
interesante es como que yo en cuando
creo eso me parece que hay una pared
donde uno termina en algún lugar termina
el prueba que plantea esta pregunta es
que hay un centro
segundos bueno algunos estudios de la
del espacio no hay centro no hay arriba
ni abajo que todo es simultáneamente al
mismo tiempo es y no es total es lo
finito es que va y viene entonces no no
es una pared en la con la que te topas
sino la pared de la idea que tiene que
ver con lo que con lo que dice rufo
porque si él si hay un un fin en el
universo tal vez haya como una vuelta y
después tiene que volver a hacerse
tendríamos que invitar a como se llama
la señora que estuvo con nosotros la
semana pasada con los vinos vaya a
hablar del universo es una candidata
astronauta de origen latinoamericano a
la que bien le irá retamal hace un
máximo hace varios años ya entonces
podríamos invitarla a era una científica
una matemática científica entre vive en
quebec en algún lado en que empezamos la
entrevista
y traemos a la de los vinos también
bien amigos aquí llegamos al final de
nuestro programa ha sido siempre un
gusto compartir esta hora con ustedes
estaremos de regreso el próximo el
próximo viernes estuvieron hoy en los
micrófonos para la uma martínez leonardo
quien les salva rojo valencia nos
despedimos como siempre con una canción
dedicada a los espías así que el que al
que le tocó pasar la escuchándonos pues
esperemos que también sean o no se
escuchan no hace falta son máquinas
adiós